de la guerre.
Dans les rues de Lviv,
la vie semble normale,
mais des signes nous rappellent
qu'ici, le deuil est perpétuel.
Les bouquets de fleurs n'ont
jamais été aussi nombreux
dans toutes les mains,
de toutes les couleurs.
Diana aes
de son ami militaire.
"Avant le 1er avrrt,
j'étais convaincue que mes amis
resteraiet saufs",
confie-t-elle.
Les funérailles de Yurii ont
lieu en re militaire, Taras.
Deux soldats morts dans
n de Louhansk,
dans l'est de l'Ukraine;
deux pères de famille.
(en ukrainien)
"Maintenant, leurs enfants sont
des orphelins, dit cette femme,
comme dene."
(chant religieux)Ils sont venuss
pour rendre hommage à ceux
qui ont défendu leur pays.
Dans cette église, où sont
célébrées les funérailles de
militaires, la scène est devenue
presque quotidienne.
Sur les visages se liteine.eine.
"Soyons braves, ne baissons pas
les bras et vivons dans l'espoir
de la vis pour apaiser
la douleur qui ronge
iniens.
(en ukrainien)
roit qu'il faut
surmonter l'épreuve,
ces pertes.
(en ukrainien)
"Sinon, c'est l'ennemi qui
l'emporte et nous détruit."adie,
un geste symbolique : chacun
veut coueux militaires
des plus belles fleurs
qui soient.
Ici Louis Blouin, Radio-Canadai